first their games come yeah buddy of the
beers in I don't know
I go no you seen you've seen hitman
though so it's all bad that's true yeah
yeah like it was it was great I mean it
was more of the same which is exactly
why I wonder if I want to see exactly
I mean they've changed tiny little
details but you know it's you know what
you're getting you're getting if you
played any of the Hitman season one it's
that again and I'm perfectly fine with
that
yeah they nailed the formula first time
so really though they were making some
tweaks like quality of life stuff right
yeah yeah so they're actually they're
doing a really interesting thing
actually so anyone who buys hitman 2
gets all of season one included for free
right so all of the areas and they've
all been updated very slightly and
little tweaks made to them so stuff like
there's a long bar outside that you can
hide in cameras now rather than just
getting a notification saying you've
been spotted you get a little
picture-in-picture thing and you can see
their vision cones if you go into
indistinct mode so there's little
changes like that and you get you get a
briefcase now as well all right which
the classic roof yeah is actually and it
feels cool this - a wonder iron with a
briefcase that contains a rocket
launcher in so stuff like that and you
know those updates apply to the old maps
as well but of course hitman 2 is not
gonna be episodic which I think it's a
shame like most people seem to really
not like the episodic yeah I was I was
always turning it in a way of that like
to be episodic statement I spent more
time in one area and did all like the
challenges got like the bonuses and
stuff but then I can also kind of
appreciate people's dislike for that
because a lot of people did just want
like I just want to sink like 30 hours
into a full hit my experience now yeah I
can I can definitely understand the
criticism but I just think it suited
much to my surprise cuz I didn't like it
before it happened I was really against
it and then I actually sat down and
played hitman season 1 I was like ya
know this really works it really works
because it allows like you said it
allows you to just play that one map for
10 hours or more and really get to know
it inside out and that's how you get to
become or get to feel like you are a
47 is because you know the map inside
out that makes up for your lack of
actual assassination
I managed to get a full run of killing
both of them passing su only no
unfortunately I didn't quite I'll save
up for when I'm 20 I was deep into just
the Miami dope but for now it was a
relatively standard run i electrocuted
the arms dealer I really wanted to just
knock a night with a coconut bar thought
is it's probably you know nice own
exotic for the demo right exactly
exactly when it gets the real thing I'll
just fully just walk up to him smash it
with a coconut so yeah I killed him
disguised myself as him and then went in
and scanned the picture of target into
like this android robot thing that was
like a murderous assassinating machine
is hitman what do you expect true I mean
it does it's that classic thing of like
you've disguised yourself as someone who
just happens to be another bald guy yeah
like if you want to be safe he actually
had a very distinction he had a happen
no bar code tattoo
no no bar code tattoo and then yeah for
the for the second half so taking out
the race car driver
disguise myself as a giant pink flamingo
standard yeah as you do and how did I
actually take right now so here are the
two possible outcomes of this meeting
one you will leave this place in this
country for good and that will be the
huh
both targets down well done 47 head for
an exit and was meet again soon
[Music]
that's the old late my own hitman levels
of I think blood money had one when you
were going through mighty grow as a
giant chicken I don't think season one
had much of like the the weird funny
levels yeah of a price serious the level
was probably aren't as funny but
definitely the sense of humor I think
was still there and it is definitely
still there in hitman 2 and it's one of
my favorite bits of it like there's a
moment when I was on my way taking out
the race car driver and I was disguised
as the pink flamingo who is meant to be
blackmailing her and that's how I
managed to get into her sort of like
secret court Jaros obviously and the guy
who's already sat there comments on my
outfit and says oh are you here for a
job interview and I'm like yeah and he's
like oh who's your suit at the dry
cleaners or something
you get job application what what
something like that if you don't mind me
saying so your particular choice of
attire is maybe a little bit I don't
know off for a job interview honey
nice suit does that the cleaners and you
couldn't find anything else to wear
correct you must lead a very interesting
life
you have no idea I think there is
something very darkly humorous about
that yeah and I think it works really
well and especially when you're in a
pink flamingos outfit I think it works
even better and I really hope they kind
of ramp that up I think the right I
think the first season was a little bit
too serious and I really hope for this
one that they ramp that up and so far I
think Hitman is a really good indication
of what they're trying to do and it's
definitely a lot more colorful than a
lot of what season 1 was like yeah so
they've done the edge Lord thing with
the nuns
exactly now they've spent time being a
bit more serious and and they're like
alright we found our feet again let's do
the pink flamingo thing exactly yeah so
I really hope they continue to ramp it
up and yeah I've really enjoyed it I
mean at the end of the day it is very
still very similar to the first season
except the episodic thing which I think
is the biggest change and a few other
little changes in terms of gameplay as
well but yeah I think I'm really looking
forward to it it's definitely one of my
most anticipated games of the year it
feels like the nicest thing to say is
that it's more of the same but like a
little bit nicer a little bit more there
yeah yeah because yeah like you say they
can't I just nailed it first time yeah
exactly that was the best hit man game
would never have yeah definitely and
like I didn't have a huge amount of
experience with the series before hitman
season 1 of the reboot
I played absolution and wasn't really a
huge I played them all really yeah and
when when the when season 1 came out I
was like this is what hit me supposed to
feel yeah yeah I really want to tell you
what they are really one a James Bond
game this is the first time you said
though I think it would be so good I
really want that but for now I'll make
do you're not gonna be able to put in
like a mad James Bond a shagging make it
minigame
when on its disgusting it's not
disgusting stuff then yeah bring a
burger by Dave I want a burger night
you